good afternoon thanks for coming to my
presentation this presentation is about
story of a Australian ISP and how they
were trying to deal with their big data
and how we with a very small team were
able using by using bigquery and data
flow to help them finally get useful
insights out of it
so I going to tell you a little bit more
about myself first so I didn't mention
before my name is public I Eve I'm a
software engineer I've been in the
industry for a bit longer than 13 years
and I work for shine technologies shine
technologies is a consultancy company
based in Melbourne Australia or danunder
as you call it here and and we basically
help customers and one of our customers
the customer of this story is just right
I'm also a Google developer expert for
the Google cloud platform and although I
come from Australia I'm sorry to tell
you it's not gonna be Australian accent
here because I'm originally from
Argentina so plenty of Spanish accent
here ok so let's talk a little bit about
Telstra so Telstra it's one of the
largest ISP and mobile operator in
Australia they they own most of the
mobile network and the actual telephone
network in Australia and they provide
services like home Internet access
mobile access
broadband access as well and they have a
lot of accounts customers between you
know home internet access and mobile
access and stuff like that they have
more than 20 million accounts and if you
take into account that people in
Australia's the population is 24 million
that's a fair share there are a very
large shopper a you know company they
have more than 32,000 cly employees and
they make a lot of money but there is
something particular about them which is
that they have a lot of data to process
so all those stuff they're gonna tell
you it's actually about a smaller
business unit of Telstra which is
Telstra media and they are a big digital
publisher and and what they do is they
they own several you know very
high-profile websites in Australia and
as many as you might know in Australia
sports we like sports quite a lot so two
of these websites are the AFL the
Australian Football League and the NRL
the National Rugby League and this
websites especially in when they're in
season games have been playing stuff
like that you can imagine the people is
constantly checking the results and
stuff like that so they get a lot of
traffic so around 5,000 requests per
second which is quite a lot and also if
you would imagine you know the websites
they have the central space with all the
information you know stuff that would be
of interest but they also have digital
real estate space that they take
advantage of so what do they do with the
his face they put lots and lots of ads
so what they do with this ad is
basically they use targeted advertising
to generate revenue and this targeted
advertising
it's basically through basic
demographics and which means that we
have several data points the way that
they are able to serve the ass is using
google publishers or DFP as an ad server
and every time and that is being shown
that's us that's what we call impression
or someone clicks on an ad we get a log
entry and that log entry contains a lot
of very interesting data points that we
can use and they make a lot of actually
information out of it so imagine 15,000
requests per second you know hitting our
page these web pages if we were try to
collect all this stuff it would turn
into five billion impressions per month
or something around like three terabytes
per month of information just super in
perspective the each person is 4.5
billion years so
put everything into context was the year
2007 almost 10 years ago and our
customer Telstra they say why don't we
start getting some useful information
out of all these you know lots all this
stuff we were generating but they found
out that it wasn't that easy to do back
in that time using GFP because you know
imagine businesspeople trying to
generate these reports it was
time-consuming the stuff they were
trying to find out it was very difficult
to finance such large amount of data and
whenever they were able to get you know
anything out of it it took them a long
time and one of the things that were
finally bit limiting was also you know
the there wasn't any out-of-the-box
visualizations that they they could use
so they call us and they say you know
can you help us so we've been working
with them before and we decide to
assemble a team so this business unit of
salsaria
is a relatively independent business
unit they have their own budget and they
can do certain innovation so we assemble
the team to two engineers one ba and
that was all we had so we say okay how
we can you know tackle this problem so
we try to analyze all this data and we
did with you know anyone will do back in
2007 try to put it in data warehouses
you know Oracle instances using servers
like renting or on service rack and
second structure which a lot of
headaches of course because it wasn't
really you know easy to get every time
we want new server it could take
six months together approve and then
another maybe three months until we
finally would get the actual server and
then configurations stuff like that
which takes time and is suspensive and
there was the demand of that I was such
a huge amount of data that we were only
able to look and analyze just a 10%
imagine trying to run queries on an
Oracle instance like you know data
warehouse and stuff like that and it
turned out that it was very costly for
this business unit and one of the major
problems they had is every time we were
getting more data it was hard to scale
as I said before getting a new server
waiting six to eight months to get it
actually in and even paying for some
stuff that we might not be using all the
time so at a very high level this is how
our solution looked like so we had the
request coming to our web pages and and
we were using as I mentioned before
double-click for publishers to serve the
ads and we were importing all these lots
and trying to put them in these data
warehouses but things didn't really work
as we expected we entered a little bit
like this putting out fires all the time
so you can see there the two engineers
and the VA so things like you know
running out of space and the database
having to contact DBA is - you know
resize table spaces and having hard
drives breaking down and someone calling
us and telling us look you're all data
you you're not gonna be able to use all
this data until probably two or three
days until we recover all the backups
and everything is back online and it
wasn't releasing
so we came to realize that we were
caring too much about all this
infrastructure it was a huge overlap for
us to try to you know take care of all
these situations but we really wanted to
get results out of all this data that
was all we really care so back in 2007
we found ourself in a dead-end moving
this data from DFP to our internal
infrastructure was very difficult and we
took a long time we saturated all the
networks because of the traffic we were
generating so we're constantly getting
calls and people are knowing because you
know everything was running slow and
trying to run queries over such huge
amount of data it was really really slow
and I'm not talking about minutes or
hours it might take days we might just
you know kick off the query come back
the next day and hope that it will
actually finish sometimes we might just
crash and we would have to contact DBA
so they could you know tune the database
a little bit more so back in 2007 this
problem was really really big for us and
we didn't really know what to do so we
found ourselves drawn in all this data
but trying desperately to get insights
out of it so a long time after that
would we basically put this in a drawer
or in a back burner as we say in
Australia 2012 several years later
things have changed quite a lot so
Google was offering cloud services and
this is what they were offering back in
2012 and we heard about a few things up
engine stop storage but we noticed
something very interesting there which
was bigquery so with the other engineer
we sir you know
what is this bigquery thing I'm sure you
appear quite a lot about bigquery
already you know it's been this is the
second day actually of the of GCP next
just gonna tell you what was very
interesting for us so it's annalistic as
a service and this was a very important
point for us no ops so you know stop
worrying about infrastructure and
problems and situations like that you
don't we didn't need to think on
installing bigquery anywhere or setting
up clusters or configuring things or
anything of that just create an account
putting data and querying the data it
was able to disable 2x2 scale to panda
bytes which is what we were looking for
and he has a sickle interface so as I
mentioned before we were using you know
Oracle we were familiar with sickle it
was perfect for us which just you know
pretty much use the same syntax and get
the data out and it's really really fast
so one ourselves can we actually you
know use this bigquery tool to solve
this problem we were having back in 2007
so we removed the dust off of the whole
problem to grout I started thinking and
we found out that it was impossible
there was a way of solving all this
problem so we were able to get all these
locks at 7 lakhs from double-click for
publishers and put them in cloud storage
and since with bigquery is very easy to
import data directly from cloud storage
using you know getting CSV files we put
everything in bigquery and then we
connected it to a table and we were
finally able to get the insides out so
all of these you know impossible things
we couldn't achieve before all of the
sudden became possible we were able to
move the data extremely fast because we
were you know within the same
infrastructure we didn't need to
download that as we were doing before we
stopped worrying so much about the
infrastructure no more calling DBAs no
more breaking networks or broke down
servers so stuff like that our costs
exponentially reduced and these long
hours or maybe days hoping that a query
with finish all of this I returned in
two seconds just imagine seconds to get
your results out and this allowed our
customer Costra to get extremely fast
time to get their insights out of all
these logs
another very interesting things we found
using the query where that was great for
doing ad hoc reports so I remember once
the VA came to me and said I'm about to
go to a very important meeting with the
stakeholders and I need to query around
two or three years worth of data can you
do it yes just sit there rot some sicko
take up as I mentioned before very easy
to move the data from DFP to be query
because it was all within Google
infrastructure and we were using Java
we're still using Java for most of the
stuff we do so it was very natural for
us to use the SDK so as you might know
bigquery has an SDK in Java Python and a
few other languages so we're using Java
SDK and it was really cost effective for
us but how cost effective so if you just
try to you know calculate paying for
DBAs paying for your servers paying for
people looking after the whole
infrastructure I don't think you can get
it for any less tab you know 40 50 K per
month for us ended up being just 1,500
per month per hundred terabytes pretty
so I'm gonna tell you a few things we
learned when we were using bigquery that
I'd like to share with you one very
interesting thing we found there was the
case so it was very useful for us to
save money so bigquery has allows you to
cache the result of the queries so when
you run a query and if you display their
query options and tick that use cache
results it will basically cache the
results and next time you run the query
you won't pay for that so this here is
an example this query will process
eleven point five gigabytes so when runs
it takes two seconds and as I said tell
us before it actually process eleven
point five gigabytes but when we run it
the second time you can see that the
results just come from the cache so you
don't pay for the process to process
that that again another very useful
thing we found with the table decorators
table decorators allow you to get a
snapshot of your data and it's very
useful for when you're you have a table
where you're constantly streaming
information in so for example this table
if I do select star which is not a
recommend thing to do it's gonna process
wanna go through force 460 gigabytes and
if I put the table decorator in just to
restrict the last hour you see how it
gets dusty rust to be reduced to 67
megabytes
another thing we found very useful was
the the idea of start with small data
sets so when you're writing your queries
and you're trying to figure out how
you're going you want to have your
sequence and you need to join to several
tables and stuff like that it's always a
good idea to save the data to a small
table like just maybe thousand rows a
hundred thousand or something like that
so you can see here for example if I was
to play with this table for example just
doing that query would take would
process eleven point five gigabytes
however if I save only one thousand
records the table gets reduced to
thirty-eight kavik kilobytes which is
completely different and this is the
last tip for bigquery
another thing we found very useful is as
we were using bigquery it's very easy to
forget tables along the way so you you
play with tables you get several
gigabytes of worth of data in tables so
anything is actually used at time to
leave feature that you can also be used
in data sets but here is an example on
the table upon using the Java SDK to
just set it expiration time in this case
is just a minute
and once you apply the change the table
will be removed so it's very good when
you have in temporary tables you can
just set an expiration time and I just
want to reiterate just to engineers that
was the team
so we decided to move to the next stage
right we had all these stuff going
getting all the locks from DFP and we
say one what I'm trying you know real
time we merely started seeing a few very
interesting things about it so one thing
we the at the campaign managers would be
able to get very good feedback about
their how the ads were going and as a
consequence of that that we'll be able
to modify maybe they weren't targeting
the right demographics they want to
change something they were able to
change it on the fly and that allowed
the business to actually move with the
data make decisions as the things were
actually happening now after they
happened and this batch processing we
were doing before of you know taking
data out of DFP it was great but it was
running every night and had a slow
turnaround time and in very interesting
in for us was the well factor so imagine
seeing a map of Australia hip map with
different points where you're getting
your impressions by geolocation and you
know distributing the population or
maybe showing you know the if it was
tablet desktop or or mobile phones so we
decided to use the streaming stuff the
bigquery has so Bakura has a streaming
API and the way we implemented this was
creating a very simple JavaScript at
that it was basically just pinging
the one I'm very simple server app and
every time someone was you know seen an
ad
maybe visiting a website that was
directly pinging our server that way
impressions and clicks were directly
streamed to bigquery and in order to be
able to see results much more easily and
and save money we were using table
decorator so we could reduce the
threshold of terrible world queries or
maybe just about the last ten minutes
you could see much bigger changes and
then we built ad a dashboard using the
three the three it's a JavaScript
library for you know doing that graphs
and stuff like that and this is how our
solution look at a very very high level
so as I mentioned before we had our the
requests hitting our servers we deploy
our up to App Engine and then we were
streaming every every single request to
with all this log information directly
to bigquery here is the demo of a part
of the app so let me show you how it
works
so what you can see there there is each
dot it's several impressions actually in
that geographic zone geographic area and
you can see there how we actually
splitting the whole the whole amount the
total impressions by state in Australia
and we're also getting an average of
impressions per minute and splitting
between mobile tablet and online online
will be the desktop so let's move to the
back to the slides again just to
engineers that was the team just two of
us okay so things are gonna went really
interesting you know we were able to
first analyze all this amount of data
process it and get inside the Amir to
using bigquery and then have this
streaming thing going on and they the
the business started realizing how
powerful bigquery was so they engage
that a scientist and what they wanted to
do is to alter the distribution in the
sample set to be more representative of
the audience so complex the statistical
things and we gave them an extract of
our data and they went away did some
simulations and stuff like that and they
came back with a statistical model very
simple just half a page simple maths
which is get it done we got it done in
around you know maybe half an hour just
29s of sequel toaster and our customer
toaster was really happy where they
wanted more so we get them we get more
data to the data scientist data
scientists went away
run their simulations again and after
three four months they came back with
something like this like crazy complex
thing so we were completely lost
something like 30 pages of
specifications operations aggregations
at several levels the way that the small
work you needed to access billions of
rows to derive these deeper insights
they wanted to get out and it became too
complex to be written in sickle and one
of the things we were actually trying to
do is you know being able to have
something that I could go to you know be
a maintainable product just recently
production and use it so we wanted to
have unit tests right unit tests being
able to have something we could work and
iterate on it it was that realizing that
we needed kind of you know the MapReduce
style of analysis to solve these kind of
problems and that's when data flow came
to us so this is actually part of a
funny story and as part of all these
interesting adventures we have with
bigquery we engage part of the Google
engineers that work on bigquery and they
they were this is back 2000 and 2014 f
2014 beginning of 2015
and back then dataflow was in alpha
Elliott file access so they invite us to
start testing and playing with data flow
and we found that it was really really
great for what we needed
of course now data flow is in production
generally available just gonna again you
probably hear a lot about data flow
already it's gonna quickly tell you it's
massively parallel and scalable so you
can run complex operations at scale it's
it's at a higher level than MapReduce
all the stuff you basically do with my
reviews imagine that you get a higher
level of instruction with much more
common operations and you can actually
change common things like group I or
maybe simple transformations or stuff
like that together and it has a service
part an SDK it's great for doing ETL but
it was it is also really really good for
doing complex analysis and that's what
we really needed you know doing these
complex resolving this complex problem
and a very interesting thing is that
it's fully managed again no worries
about infrastructure we didn't need to
install any Hydra war install or
configure clusters or do anything and
it's sort of in that up so imagine just
to developers to software engineers who
can really try to do that it's very cost
efficient so we went and implemented our
model you've seen data flow and this is
how our solution looked like so we still
had you know the batch side of the thing
the the solution just getting the logs
out of DFP putting in a bigquery and
then taking advantage of the streaming
side we got all the data from bigquery
we implemented our statistical model
using data flow and put all the results
back to bigquery and then we were
finally able to get insights this
insights we were looking for
unfortunately I can't really tell you
too much about this model because it's
under NDA so I really like to tell you
more but yeah that's the reality of it
and
in terms of the cost imagine imagine a
game you know trying to manage big
clusters and having people helping you
with the infrastructure or maybe to set
up operating system or its town in
Hyderabad
you can't really get for anything lower
than probably now thirty case or
something per month for us was only $700
per month and we are processing around
50 terabytes so let's move to a few data
flow tips things we learned when we're
using data flow so a few things we found
that it's not a good idea try to do you
need to be aware of long-running
operations when you're writing your
transforms so as you might know
transforms are actually the atomic
operations you do you get an input data
you do something with the data and then
you output the result and you need to be
aware this can this will run multiple
times and it will scale with your data
if you have billions of rows will you
trying to read from bigquery and you
have billions of rows you will actually
be doing this billion time so if you're
trying to go to the network and do
something it's not gonna be a good idea
it's gonna turn out pretty slow it's not
possible to put everything in memory so
if you're trying to process two
terabytes don't try to put memory that's
something that maybe the data scientists
coming from a complete different
background we're doing in for us was a
challenge to adapt the whole thing in a
more distributed way and that Fleur has
P collection that can really serve for
that aspect and another thing that you
need to be aware of is the hotkeys the
hotkeys are come from a very common
operation do you do with data flow which
is for example group by key where you
have a key and that key my have
several actual values matching with
their key like millions of them so if
you see you know your craft and you see
your computer and instance running you
see that they are very hot two or three
might have very high CPU and the others
are idle that means you have a hot key
and there are solutions for that I'm
gonna touch about that later
a good thing when you're working with
data flow is to take advantage of the
local runner so data flow has several
runners and when you start working with
a you know when we're developing this
model we've of course started with small
data sets and you know writing our
program and testing it and going through
small iterations and then you can
actually move to the GCB Runner so this
is a good way to deal with the hotkeys
so for example when you need to do
something like aggregations over this
large set of data and you can actually
use the combined functions so they
combine functions allow you to basically
distribute these values that you have
for several kisum into worker nodes and
each teach it shows that our flow the
the semantics of your of your problem
your program that you're trying to
implement so they have several steps you
basically initialize the accumulator you
define accumulators to where you will be
doing something like for example some in
the values and then you need to have a
function that I will add each element to
the accumulator and then of course you
need to merge and then you might merge
again and then you extract the output
and this is how it looks in code you
need to stand from the combined function
and specify inputs accumulator type and
output type
and you got there the initialize
function the add inputs match
accumulators and extract outputs and
when you want to use it just basically
use the combined per key and create an
instance of your of your combined
function the composite transforms this
is another one that we found really
useful so as I was telling you this
model is pretty complex several
aggregations several levels joints and
stuff like that and we once we actually
finish implementing the whole thing it
was a big mess a lot of nodes connecting
each others completely crazy
so composite transforms allow you to
group related operations and you can
have something much easier to digest so
the way you to implement is you extend
these P transform class and specify an
input type output type and then you
change the two transforms together so
for example here where you were having a
initial transform that we put in this K
P collection and then we apply a second
transform on top of it and we result we
return the results and we went for
something like that and this is just a
small portion of the whole big model to
just one out and you can see how much
simple it gets in a game I want to
reiterate the team was just two
engineers just the two of us trying to
deal with this big problem so at the
moment what we're doing now is we're
trying to move from a batch mode because
the model was basically conceived in a
batch mode so then the natural evolution
will be in streaming mode so you know
our data scientists taking more data and
they are running their simulations and
stuff like that
so we can actually move to the next
stage so just to wrap up Telstra was
having a lot of issues trying to analyze
all this amount of that I had by using
bigquery we were finally able to allow
them to extract useful insights out of
all this amount of data when we were
given this very complex model dataflow
allows to actually implement it in a way
that it could be maintainable and we
could iterate on on it and using GCP
gave us access to a very powerful and
scalable infrastructure infrastructure
at a fraction of the cost compared to
actually you know rolling out our own
infrastructure or renting infrastructure
from Telstra and we didn't really need a
big team so I thought thank you
you